hi I'm Nicolas be at Freedom Fest in Las
Vegas and right now we're talking with
Jeffrey Rogers Hummel he's an economist
at San Jose State and a historian by
training as well Jeff thanks for talking
to us we who have been writing the hell
out of monetary expansion and the
problems that's causing what has been
happening to the money supply over the
past several years well um it depends on
what you look at let me back up before I
answer that question because I think
that what's happened with a lot of
libertarians and free-market economists
is they've fallen into the trap of
generals fighting the last war so the
focus has been on how central banks
generate inflation and i think that the
concern about inflation is is overblown
because the whole nature of central
banking has changed and the financial
crisis well why have central banking
changes that because central banks are
now competing against one another well
it's yeah partially it's because central
banks are competing so you have a
globalized economy which means that you
know when speculators go up against
central bank central bank's always lose
speculators always win but also in
highly developed countries are in
developed countries you have highly
developed financial systems where most
of the money that people hold is not got
created by the government it's created
privately by banks and other financial
institutions and that means that
governments senior rich the amount of
revenue that government gets from
creating money has has become trivial
and so that creates a lot less incentive
for central banks to increase the money
supply in order to cover government
expenditures but we have been increasing
the money so yeah well that's what
happened yeah but if you look at what's
what really happened is that when when
all hell broke loose in September of
2008
bernanke took two steps one was he
engaged in an unprecedented increases in
the monetary base which other things
being equal would have been highly
inflationary and at the same time he
began adopting a practice that had been
talked about before and already adopted
by other central banks which is paying
interest on reserves which other things
being equal would have been deflationary
and so those two things have actually
offset each other why did he do that why
did he pay interest on reserves well
there are several reasons and some of
them are a little bit arcane but first
of all ever since deregulation and the
monetary measures began behaving more
erratically central banks have focused
on targeting interest rates and by
paying interest on reserves that
supposedly allows them to target
interest rates more closely then paying
interest on reserves is an idea that's
been around for a long time and even
Milton Friedman talked about it for
different reasons and it's a way of
getting banks to hold increasing
reserves and eliminating the tax that
reserve requirements are holding
reserves input so it was a way of
helping the banks and then it also is
has well I better not go into a bit the
clear the way the Fed runs the clearing
system they want banks holdem or more
reserved and especially in a crisis
where you're worried about them not
having enough money and all of that and
and and this this reflects an underlying
change in the nature of central banking
in the past central banking was about
just pumping money into the system
affecting the rate of inflation and
hopefully dampening the business cycle
which we know they didn't do but what
now what's now the the central bank has
become central banking has become the
new central planning central banks are
now interested in controlling interest
rates controlling the structure of
interest rates and controlling the
allocation of credit and if you
look at the asset side of the fed's
balance sheet all of the new assets that
they've acquired the fact that they're
engaging in this operation twist where
they're trying to affect the yield on
different maturities of Treasury
securities shows that they're trying to
influence them and they're also
borrowing on the liability side in other
words in the past when central banks
created money what central banks bought
assets they just created the money but
now they're also they've also the
Federal Reserve has become a giant
fannie or freddie where it actually
borrows money on one end and real ends
it on the other end no you said earlier
that monetarists are fighting the last
war it seems or free market economy
libertarian yeah and so is this the
twilight of you know we know keynes is
wrong and but is it that milton friedman
and monetarist theory in general is no
longer applicable to the world yeah
which I would say the opposite Milton
Friedman won the debate among
macroeconomists about the source of
inflation in other words in
macroeconomics you have the business
cycle economic growth and in sustained
inflation is the three big problems and
on sustained inflation the Keynesian
won't even admit that they ever denied
that money was the source of sustained
inflation so that debate has been so
thoroughly one that Bernanke is very
committed to preventing both deflation
and significantly high inflation so it
really reflects the victory on that
particular issue of the monetarist now
on the business cycle there's no
consensus among macro economists
whatsoever and in fact the recent
financial crisis has sort of brought
back all of the old debates that
occurred during the Kings versus the
classics worry out of it well let's get
a little Austrian on this is it that the
business cycle was never properly
understood by
you know earlier forms of economics
apart from the Austrians well my take on
this which some Austrian economists are
not going to be happy with this is that
all all theories of the business cycle
or wrong that's why there's no consensus
in the perfect profession when I teach
intermediate and graduate macro I give
over half a dozen different business
cycle theories and most of them get at
least one variable going in the wrong
direction in terms of a stylized picture
of the business cycle so there are
weaknesses and all the theories I think
Austrian business cycle theory has some
insights but I also think it has some
weaknesses and and therefore it's it's
it's a phenomenon that nobody at this
point understand so perfectly will get
me know a lot more than we used to but
nobody understands it perfect we'll get
to fiscal policy in a second but in
terms of monetary policy what what
should be the next step if we want to
not hammer the economy flatter than it's
been well I think we need to get rid of
the Federal Reserve and and and
privatize the monetary system is that a
is that a you know and I don't want to
say because it hasn't been done it
shouldn't even be discussed in the past
but is that a viable option either
politically or metaphysically well it's
theoretically viable and politically
it's not currently viable but that
doesn't mean I mean in other words if
you go even if you want to figure out
halfway measures you've got to figure
out where you're ultimately going and
when you have a clear idea of where
you're ultimately going that allows you
to evaluate halfway did you ever think
you would live in a time where you would
see college campuses you know when Ron
Paul or somebody's speaking and they
chant like college students chanting and
the fête like it was the Vietnam War um
when I was when I was younger I hope for
that and then I got older and more
cynical and so I'm pleasantly surprised
well let's talk about fiscal policy you
are
you have been known to say that a
default a Treasury default is not only
inevitable but it would be a welcome
development why is it inevitable well
it's an it's inevitable because you have
because the entitlement programs have
been running on a pay-as-you-go basis
that makes them very sensitive to both
demographic factors and economic
fluctuations they have these huge
shortfalls and this is not just through
the US but it's true of all nearly all
of the of the welfare states and their
different ways of measuring and get
different numbers but but the shortfall
is not something that's happening in the
future it exists already and it
represents say that now are explained
that okay most well are going to say no
no all right we haven't we have until
2030 well we have it we have entitlement
programs that have made promises in row
future and then we have expected taxes
in the future and the shortfall is
between the present value of its
expected taxes and the present value of
promised benefits and what that
shortfall represents is how much either
taxes have to be raised or benefits have
to be cut or some combination of the two
there is no other alternative so when
you won that what i mean by that
shortfall being here in the present is
that it tells us that the government is
eventually going to have to do one or or
they won't they do that rather than give
up I mean this is if we go back to the
early 80s and Ronald Reagan who just 20
years before it talked about Social
Security as a horrible big government
program in the early eighties when he
saved Social Security he talked about
the long one thing we can down the road
that worse the problem get okay so this
is going to lead to default in other
words so so you have to you have to
consider what are the government's
options one is cutting benefits and I
don't think that's politically going to
happen raising taxes taxes since the
beginning of the Cold War federal
revenues as a percentage of GD
p have been bumping up against twenty
percent of gdp which is an astonishing
statistic when you think about it
because they've been enormous changes in
the tax code and the total bite out of
the economy has stayed the same and even
if we raise taxes to as high as they
were during world war two which is the
highest federal revenues were that
doesn't get you even to twenty five
percent of gdp and even without interest
on the debt expenditures are projected
to go to at least thirty five percent of
gdp so taxes aren't going to solve the
problem partially for the reasons we've
been talking about inflation is not
going to close the gap inflation is no
more able to close the gap than an
excise tax on chewing gum and the result
is that at some point holders of
Treasury securities are going to
recognize that these unfunded
liabilities are going to affect the
fiscal capabilities of the government
and then you have the same situation
that happened to greece happening to the
US where you have a a rapid shift from a
high confidence environment we won't
either we either won't be able to will
pay a mass of interest premium on our
most rates will go out it will make
which will make things worse so so it'll
it things will move very fast it'll be
like the collapse of the soviet yeah
this is yeah this is the joke of that
and nobody ever sees an intro you know
it's like jumping out of a window on the
thirtieth floor and everybody's like you
know an interest problem it's fine it's
fine it's fine until you hit the red and
suddenly right it's over why would it be
a good thing well in the short run it's
going to be painful but in the long run
it'll be a good thing because first of
all government debt and these
entitlement programs represent future
tax liabilities and a repudiation of
government debt means the elimination of
future tax liabilities and I think
that's a desirable outcome all I would I
mean it's like a bankruptcy or a
liquidation ray we get to start over
right we get to start all four but also
it may
that you may also see as government
securities fall in value you may also
see depending on how correctly people
anticipate their future tax liabilities
the rise and the value of private assets
including human capital which will
offset the losses with respect to
Treasuries the second reason it's it's
desirable is because it's almost a
balanced budget amendment with teeth
unfortunately that's not completely true
because governments when they default
often can go back and borrow more but at
least it makes it more difficult for
them to do so and the final reason is I
think this represents the Achilles heel
of the welfare state in other words all
nearly all the welfare states are facing
this kind of fiscal crisis and I think
that once this fiscal crisis plays out
the welfare state will end up being as
much a figment of the past as the
command economy and the only really
important question is what will replace
it what well what would be your option
well your preference to let a fair
economy right and and a night watchman
stage and well ours even at 22 well a
night watchman state as it is a modest
step in the right direction okay I want
to thank you jeffrey rogers hummel of
Santa be seated the independent
Institute for talking with reason TV I'm
Nicholas
you